[Musique]
pour être honnête avec toi, jouer dans la NBA ne me manque pas, ne
manque pas la carrière, ce furent 20 belles
années, c'est très chanceux de jouer
aussi longtemps et mais maintenant, tu sauras,
regarde-le jusqu'au bout.  ma fille ma fille
joue tous les jours donc j'aime la voir
évoluer mais c'est tout
[Musique]
ma fille m'a donné le meilleur
conseil qui m'inquiétait un peu de
faire de nous un film qui n'a jamais fait
ça  quelque chose comme ça avant et nous
étions dans une maison et nous
parlions en famille et mon petit Levin
toi ou Gianna va bien papa tu
nous dis toujours de poursuivre nos rêves alors mec,
elle a 11 ans mec
oh donc j'ai dû me lever  et foncez
[Musique]
vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous